good morning how's everybody doing today
cool my name is Kavya and I'm here today
to talk to you about time in our systems
specifically the timekeeping mechanisms
they use now first things first what
even is time man I kid we're not going
to go down that path today but I'm happy
to talk physics and philosophy some
other day preferably over red wine for
our purposes today our intuitive notions
of time will suffice namely that it
moves forwards we use it to sequence
events and to make measurements now we
use time extensively in our systems
right you don't need me to stand here
and tell you this but rarely do we think
about the underlying timekeeping
mechanisms at play what do I mean well
here's an example say we have a simple
distributed key-value store everybody
here familiar with the idea for
distributed database cool so we have
three nodes and we're going to assume
that there are no failures and all our
operations succeed now say I come along
and I put key equal to V a few seconds
later I changed my mind and I put key is
equal to V 2 then you come along and you
perform a get for key what's the value
you get here it's V 2 right
and he takers for V 1 yes so the final
value you get depends on the consistency
model of the data store are we using
much sequel or are we using Cassandra
and I haven't told you anything about
the consistency model but wait a minute
this talk was supposed to be about time
and time keeping why are we talking
about consistency models
well a consistency model can be thought
of as the set of guarantees the system
provides about what events are visible
and when so it's about time in that the
consistency model encapsulate the set of
valid timelines for events in our
and these guarantees they are informed
by and and enforced by the timekeeping
mechanisms the system uses so this is
what we're interested in today what
these mechanisms are and how they affect
the properties of the system the rest of
the stock is structured as follows
I will first talk about computer clocks
in physical time we'll then talk about
other timekeeping mechanisms and the
context of spanner and react to
practical systems and finally we'll take
a step back and wrap up all right then
first things first computer clocks
so let's first concretize the model
we're working with right it's a
distributed data store which means it's
a data store spread out over several
nodes where the the features we care
about a node is that each node operates
sequentially and our nodes are separated
in that there's no shared memory they
are separated by a network and they
communicate over by shared sorry by
message passing now the reason we want
to use a distributed start is for
properties like fault tolerance and
scalability for performance which means
our data is partitioned across these
nodes and replicated okay so this is the
model we're interested in and our
question is given this is our system how
do we keep time across it well let's see
our computers have clocks my computer
has a clock can we just use them the
party lines answers to these questions
like this right hardware clocks drift
ntp man I tell you NTP the system clock
it keeps you next time but what are the
real problems with this what are the
properties we want from our timekeeping
mechanism that these don't provide to
answer that question we're going to
delve into the system clock and you
it's time to see how they work in
important caveat we but before we begin
the details vary by pretty much
everything but we do but the details
don't matter today we're after the the
higher level concepts and those remain
pretty much the same that said that's
what we will be assuming and we're not
running on an x86 processor okay so
let's start with the first hardware
clock drift now what is this hardware
and why does it matter starting from the
top when you run a command like date or
call something like time now to get the
time from your favorite programming
language this translates to a system
call to get the value of a particular
computer clock right now we have
different computer clocks we have the
system clock or the wall clock this is
the clock we're familiar with it keeps
you next time but there are other clocks
there's the monotonic o'clock there's
the monotonic raw clock and there are
others now all of these computer clocks
are software based but they are run by a
hardware clock or hardware clocks in
conjunction with the operating system
kernel let's look at an example of how
this works in practice using the system
clock so the system clock is simply a
counter right and it's run by the
hardware and the MS Carnall the way this
works is at system boot it's set to a
value to a reading based on the hardware
clock the hardware clock is is usually
the real-time clock which is a tiny chip
on the motherboard and subsequently this
counter is maintained
it's incremented by the kernel arranging
for a hardware ticker to deliver
interrupts periodically okay
conceptually this is like the kernel
telling the each pet or a different
ticker a different timer telling the
each bed hey interrupt me in 10
milliseconds so when the interrupt is
delivered to it the colonel knows that
10 milliseconds have passed and it
increments
the counter by that much now modern
watering kernels
not some water and anymore but they're
all ticklish kernels which means that
the interval the interrupts interval is
calculated dynamically alright pretty
simple so this is the system clock and
this is the hardware clocks that can
drift so when they drift what it means
that what what it means that is
different computer clocks change at
different rates so this is the real
problem that our clocks are not
synchronized let's move on to the second
ntp minute ntp everybody's you're
familiar with ntp okay so it's basically
a clock synchronization protocol it
tries to make it so it tries to make it
so our system clocks remains
synchronized with a highly accurate
clock Network and what's special about
that clock Network is the hardware that
powers it are very accurate clocks like
GPS and atomic clocks that have minimal
drift now the way it synchronizes our
computer clocks the system clocks is it
has two modes of operation it can
gradually increase or decrease that
interrupt rate this is called skewing
the clock and this is good or it can
simply jump the clock it can simply step
it or set it to a new value and this is
bad because it means our clocks the time
they keep is distant or can be
discontinuous there are other problems
with ntp for one you need these trusted
and reachable NTP servers and for
another NTP is slow on the public
Internet if can take up the hundreds of
milliseconds and this matters when
you're trying to keep things consistent
in a data story and Leslie let's talk
about the system clock the system clock
which keeps you next time now we sort of
know what you next time is it's the
number of seconds since epoch which is
some point in time
defined with respect to the UCC time
standard the other property if you next
time is it it counts it calculates a day
as having exactly 86,400 seconds okay so
if we wanted to know the thousand days
since epoch we could simply do thousand
times that 86,400 and that would give us
you next time it seems pretty reasonable
except UTC days are not a constant
86,400 seconds wait what well we're
gonna have to take a brief interlude to
talk about UTC I promise I'll keep it
short
the idea behind UTC is somewhat
bewildered
it's this like messy compromise of a
time standard between atomic time which
is kept by atomic clocks and
astronomical time which was the
old-school way of calculating time based
on the Earth's rotation why do we want a
time standard in between the two well
they both have nice properties atomic
clocks are very regular very stable but
astronomical time has the nice property
of matching up with the earth sortation
and I'm told that this is nice for
certain of for certain aspects like
navigation that's not an astronomy
unclear but anyway UTC said UTC decides
to be based on atomic time and
periodically adjust its time to sync
with the Earth's rotation so far it
doesn't sound too bad either until you
learn that the Earth's rotation
gradually slows down with time so over
time the Earth's an Earth Day takes
slowly longer than 86,400 seconds and so
to compensate for this drift UTC does
this remarkable thing of adding a second
every time then typically at midnight
UTC inserts what is called a leap second
which you may have heard of it caused a
recent CloudFlare adage that
quite large but how the leap second
works is from going from 11 59 59 the
time jumps to 11:59 60 and then goes to
midnight okay and they're in there lewd
back to you next time
so you PC can be either a UTC day can be
either of these seconds long but unix
time kept by the system clock doesn't
know how to represent this extra second
but in the long run we want our
computers idea of current time to keep
up and remain aligned with UTC right we
don't want it to have its own sense of
what the time is so what does you next
time do well in the case of a leap
second you next time simply ways it
simply repeats a second which means the
time kept by our system clock is not
monotonic so this is the real set of
problems with using computer clocks
computer clocks across different
computers do not give us synchronized
monotonic time why does this matter well
let's see with an example say we have
two nodes so all my representations in
this talk are going to be space-time
diagrams where time moves from left to
right and our perspective of a nodes
time line is represented by those
horizontal lines and events against the
system are going to be upwards and
downwards errors okay it's pretty
standard okay so two nodes now say I
come along and I put key is equal to V
but node one tends to is is
unsynchronized it's a fast node so it's
time stamps it with 150 a few seconds
later I perform another put that ends up
a note - I put keys equal to V - but no
- maybe has the right time maybe it's
slower but it time stamp set with a
lower version so although I have a newer
version of data it's time stamped with
an older time stamp so not only is our
system
consistent now we're pretty much done
for game over we can never reconcile
this inconsistency right which is why
and that brings us to the need for other
timekeeping mechanisms our systems need
to provide abstractions on physical time
as we know it in order to function
correctly so what are these other
timekeeping mechanisms well it depends
it depends on as we alluded to in the
beginning the consistency model the
system chooses to provide what
guarantees it wants to provide about how
events will be ordered and when they
will be visible but this is not this
decision it does not have a single
dimension right consistency comes with
costs for one you have availability
costs right availability is the notion
of very informally how responsive the
system is and typically the more the
higher consistency means lower
availability this is the cap theorem at
play sort of and consistency also has a
has a cost of performance right and
performance specifically means read and
write latency and therefore throughput
of the system and so while building
these systems you typically have to make
trade-offs you have to turn down and up
these knobs of consistency availability
and performance so the timekeeping
mechanism is also dependent on these
three factors now this relation between
the timekeeping mechanism and these
properties of the system is something
we'll come back to throughout the talk
for now though enough theoretical
pre-landing let's start real systems so
the first system we're going to talk
about today is a strongly consistent
data store built by Google it's called
spanner our people you're familiar with
or heard of spanner cool
so as you know then spanner is a
distributor relational database it it
allows for complex schemas and
distributed transactions which is pretty
neat
no spanner is horizontally scalable so
your data your savings table in a
banking system may live on one partition
and checking on another partition its
geo replicated for fault tolerance and
spanner really cares about being
performant right and this is an
important design consideration to note
and finally the consistency model
spanner provides is a very strong form
of consistency called external
consistency the definition is a mouthful
a globally consistent ordering of
transaction that matches the observed
commit order to see what that means
let's just work through an example so
say we have a spanner set up we have our
savings and our checking's on two
partitions each is replicated and the
application has constraint that the
minimum total balance requirement for a
user's account across their checking's
and savings accounts must be 200 now at
the beginning of the world my account
meets that criteria and then I perform a
deposit into my savings account this is
the first transaction and then a few
seconds or maybe a few hours later I
make a debit from my checking account
and this is t2 now what do we want from
this system
well we want it to never be the case
that t to the debit is visible but not
t1 the deposit right this is this is
what this is the essence captured by
globally consistent transaction order
what we're saying here is t1 and t2 our
transactions operating on different
partitions of the key space and yet
despite that we want them to be ordered
in the order of zero
by me external to the system to the
commit order that I observed No
why is this complicated or why is this
tricky well imagine this imagine one
partition is in the u.s. so team one
goes to the US partition and T to that
partition is in Europe so T two ends up
in the Europe data center and the
auditor for the bank say the bank
accounts balance police is sitting in
Europe and checking checking balances
meet that criteria now you would think
that if they had the data set the Europe
data center it's entirely possible that
they they might see t2 before t1 and we
don't want that to be the case because
then I would be in trouble and the
system would be incorrect as per in spec
so that is the idea of external
consistency okay the other thing we care
about is performance right you can
imagine one way to provide external
consistency but just putting a giant
block of the entire database but that
would sort of defeat the purpose of a
distributed database so what does this
have to do with time again well taking
those lofty goals and translating them
into our set of requirements what we're
saying we want is a consistent time line
across replicas we want to be able to
order transactions across partitions as
well and we want this order to
correspond to the observed commit order
if we are able to satisfy these three
requirements with whatever timekeeping
mechanism we choose then we obviously
get the desired consistency guarantees
we also get the desired performance now
we're not going to go into this detail
in this talk but what it allows us to do
is implement things like reads for
replicas and consistent snapshot reads
and that's what gives us the performance
that we want
all right so let's start with the
beginning as with the with the first
requirement consistent time line across
replicas now we're not going to talk
about this because there's a protocol
that we all are several protocols that
we all are I take it familiar with
consensus we can use consensus protocols
like paxos raft 3 3 phase commit
two-phase commit what have you we can
use consensus to synchronously replicate
and that would give us a consistent time
line across replicas let's talk about
the second and the third properties
which are more interesting what we want
is we want t1 to be ordered before t2
even if T even if t1 and t2 are across
the globe so let's think of one way to
do it namely using commit time stamps
right the idea of a commit time stamp is
when your transaction commits you assign
that version of the data so this is
Savannah uses MVCC so it keeps around
multiple versions of data so when the
transaction commits you timestamp that
version of that data with that timestamp
called the commit time stamp would that
work
well let's see if we had perfectly
synchronized clocks it would write t1
would be time stamped with 50 and t2 the
transaction there would be time stamped
with a hundred and that and then we
could order them based on their time
stamps and we'd be all set but we don't
have synchronized clocks so what else
could we do well if we knew exactly how
how would the uncertainty what the error
of our clocks was we could take that
into account and still use commit times
so this is what spanners true time does
true time is both the API and the
infrastructure that provides what is
effectively a globally synchronized
clock with a bounded but non zero error
right so conceptually a true time both
tracks and it exposes the uncertainty
about perceived time across the system
clocks this is the idea right so say we
have an event it occurs at a time so it
occurs an absolute time a true time that
our system clocks cannot know they
cannot know this because of drift in
because there are because of their error
margins but if we know the error margin
we can come up with an interval we can
come up with the bound that is
guaranteed to contain true time right so
in this case T the small T is true time
and that represents our interval does
this make sense so far
cool so this is what true time does it
represents time as an interval not a
point so for example if you say now true
time Jimmy now true time returns the
interval that is guaranteed to contain
true now so earliest there is the
earliest time that could be true now and
latest is the latest time that could be
true now so here we're talking about
physical time but its physical time
augmented with uncertainty information
okay
so now that we have a way to know the
uncertainty of our clocks
let's account for it so what we want is
for T ones commit time stamp to
guaranteed be less than 2 T 2's commit
time stamp and the way this works is
Spanish so when T 1 arrives at its
partition what the note does is
it sets it's commit timestamp to be the
latest time that represents now and then
it waits it waits a full uncertainty
window and only after it waits the
uncertainty window does it actually go
through the commit at that point the
changes it makes are visible to the rest
of the nodes so at that point it commits
and it replies to the client why does it
wait what the commit wait does is it
guarantees that the next transaction
will have a higher timestamp what it
what it does is it forces the client to
wait and therefore the next transaction
to be serialized at least one
uncertainty window ahead what this looks
like in practice is now let's say t2
ends up edits at the second partition
now the note is going to assign the
commit timestamp in the same way but
note that now has now moved along one
whole uncertainty window and so t2 is
guaranteed to be less than t1 now why do
we have to wait that full of uncertainty
window because for up to that time say
say our uncertainty window is 10 for up
to 10 for up to 10 milliseconds there
could be an error between my clock and
another clock right so say for example
the t1 and so going back to our original
example with the 2 notes so say that t1
ends up at a node with a slow clock
right so it's time stamp set with 50
then our sorry with a fast clock so it's
time step we'll come back to it
time's confusing okay all right so what
spanner does is you know so what's
better does essentially is it weights
out for the uncertainty right since it
uses this concept it applies that to
reeds as well we're not going to talk
about reeds today in the interest of
time but it applies the same idea it
knows the uncertainty window and so it
takes it into account to provide strong
reeds okay
so this is really really neat okay this
is neat because true time enables
externally consistent commitment I'm
stamps which in turn enables external
consistency without coordination but
true time is not perfect right this the
uncertainty window it affects the
commits time it affects the commit wage
time and so it affects the the right
latency and so the throughput of the
system which is why you need to go
through extraordinary lengths to keep
this uncertainty window very small so
Google uses a lot of very expensive and
very impressive infrastructure and it
has a special clock synchronization
protocol to keep the clocks the system
fox very tightly synchronized right so
whereas NTP goes up to 100 milliseconds
true time bomb binds it to seven
milliseconds which is pretty impressive
and this is also why no you can't have
it cool so that's about true time now
let's hop over to the other side of the
cap here and fence and talk about a
weekly consistent store react have folks
here used react
a few yes cool symma react is a
distributed key-value store so it does
not support complex schemas it just Maps
a key to a blog and it doesn't have the
notion of multi key transactions okay
now react chooses first and foremost to
be a highly available data store that is
it chooses to be available and able to
perform reads and writes it prioritizes
that over everything else and this again
is important this is an important design
consideration to note to that end the
consistency guarantees react makes a
very weak it's a specific flavor of weak
consistency is called eventual
consistency and the idea is replicas are
allowed to diverge for a period and they
will eventually converge with an example
say we have three replicas then use it a
user comes along and they put carts
equal to a that ends up a node one the
user subsequently updates the cart to
contain D and that ends up a no - now
for a period a subsequent gift for the
cart can return the empty cart if it
ends up an if the request is served by
node three it can the Deb can get a cart
with value a or it can get the cart with
D and this is totally fine in fact this
is specified by the consistency
guarantee the system makes to you
eventually though all the replicas must
converge and they must converge to the
last updated value which is the cart
containing D and this is where
timekeeping comes into play right and
our timekeeping mechanism specifically
needs to be able to determine causal
updates so it can converge to the last
updated value it needs to know that D
was D was aware
of Kart 8 and over and over wrote it so
it's causally related now the other
thing we said we cared about it was
availability right so consensus is not
an option here we want not just one
replica but all replicas are many
replicas to be able to accept reads and
writes and perform them and this in turn
means that the second thing our
timekeeping mechanism needs to be able
to do is determine conflicting updates
what do I mean by conflicting updates
well here's the example well same after
user a takes the empty card and makes it
card containing a say a different user
comes along and takes the empty card and
makes it card containing B now these two
updates are effectively concurrent right
they didn't know about each other and
therefore and therefore they conflict so
we need the timekeeping mechanism to be
able to identify updates that are causal
versus conflicting well let's see can we
use time stamps here physical time steps
sure why not
only one problem we don't have
synchronized clocks and we don't have
true time
not everybody is Google and so we need
to come up with a different timekeeping
mechanism which brings us to logical
time in the form of vector clocks now
vector clocks are logical logical clocks
and that they don't track physical time
they track logical time which is
entirely divorced from the idea of
physical time right you can think of it
as keeping versions and event counts and
ink and time stamping versions of the
data with the vector clocks okay so this
is the example we're going to be working
with we have a conflicting update so a
and B are conflicting and we have a
causal update a and D are causal and
this is the example we just
okay so let's see how effective clocks
work at the beginning of the world so
vector clock is simply an array of n n
count encounters basically with one
counter per node each node in the system
holds on to its own effector clock so
its own full vector clock at the
beginning of the worlds they're all set
to zero now each time a node observes or
performs an event it's going to
increment its count in its vector clock
by one so there's a put-on node one so
the zero went to one now note we had an
event so the zero the green zero becomes
the green one now no one has another
event so it's vector clock goes up again
and what happens here what react does is
get not only returns the objects the
cart it also passes along the vector
clock the time step in a causal context
which is really just the header of the
response so it returns both the clock
both the clock but the clock and the
cart now the user is going to put the
cart is going to update it to D and put
it and that's going to end up a note too
right so that's what the user is going
to do and the user again react dustless
where the user sends along the timestamp
that was returned to it what this
enables is causality tracking through
the system so what does know to do at
this point well it's just observed an
event so it's going to increment its
vector clock but it's also going to do
something else here it's going to do
something special to establish that it
knows off the event that happened on
node 1 it's going to set its vector
clock to the pairwise max of node once
vector o'clock and it's back to clock
okay and this captures the captures that
it knows of the other event - all right
so this is the final state of our system
and it's now time for replicas to
convert
we won't talk about how replicas
converging react but you can ask me
later Wow okay so at replica convergence
time this our question is how do we know
what versions of the data are causal and
therefore should overwrite older
versions and what versions are
conflicting and therefore should be
preserved and we're going to use vector
clocks to do this how do we do that well
the vector clock rule is if X is vector
clock is less than Y is vector clock
then X came before happened before Y so
with an example let's look at a and D
right those are the Associated vector
clocks if we take if we do a pairwise
comparison of their corresponding
elements we see that 2 0 0 is less than
2 1 0 and so carts a precedes carts de
cartes de should override cart a on the
other hand if we look at D and B we see
that two months zero is not pairwise
less than 0 0 1 and the inverse doesn't
hold as well right so we basically can't
order the vector clocks one way or
another and this means because the
vector clocks can't be ordered it means
that D conflicts with B which matches
our intuition right so this is also
pretty neat of logical clocks they give
us it means to abstract away physical
time and like focus on the ordering of
events so they they are he clever proxy
for physical time but logical clocks
also have their pitfalls for one they
need to be passed around to preserve our
causality chain and they're divorced
from physical time right so you can't
query react for data based on a physical
time stamp that you care about like you
can do with
spanner all right so we could stand here
and delve into the intricacies of
spanner and react all day but rather
than doing that I'd like to take a step
back to wrap up and talk about what we
learned today
so we first started with a discussion of
why physical time doesn't quite cut it
for disputed systems we then looked at
two very different approaches used by
two very different systems to get around
this problem right we talked about true
time and how it all meant physical
quacks no a dog meant physical time but
this uncertainty information to give us
time stamps that correspond to the wall
clock time but to give us external
consistency we then talked about a
radically different approach to the
problem at a physical time we talked
about doing away with physical Huynh
entirely and coming up with this notion
of logical time trapped by vector clocks
and this gives us means to track causal
relations and not worry about time at
all like physical time off but these
approaches are not perfect right true
time requires a globally synchronized
clock in order to work and rekordbox
don't have anything to do with physical
time which brings us to an idea that I
will have to leave you with or I'm happy
to talk about later which is hybrid
logical clocks used by cockroach TV it's
a fairly new technology and what it does
is it bridges the gap between physical
time and logical time it's pretty cool
and I encourage that but we are about
out of time I hope you leave today with
and
standing of the timekeeping mechanisms
used by these two systems specifically
but but more importantly perhaps an
appreciation for the the nuances of the
problem of timekeeping in our systems
thank you
[Applause]